What I eat in a day as a mom on a time crunch
and as someone who avoids seed oils,
artificial sugars,
dyes and preservatives at all costs.
Breakfast is done in a flash with pasture raised eggs scrambled up.
Lunch is leftover pasture raised chicken fajitas
and a slice of freshly milled
whole grain sourdough bread with bread butter
that I I also made sure to take my whole food
animal based blend of bioavailable vitamins and minerals from
birthright tribute to optimal fertility and female hormonal health.
Dinner was 100% grass fed beef meatball source from my parents farm,
a fennel salad straight from my garden
with Parmigiano Reggiano and simple dressing.
And I had a probiotic coconut yogurt with bee pollen,
berries and a drizzle of raw honey for dessert.